hello i'm sasha larkin a captain with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
here to bring you the preliminary
details as we know them so far
on officer involved shooting number
three for 20 21
today monday march 1st 2021
just afternoon lvmpd dispatch center
received a call
that there was an unknown subject male
walking through a desert area in the
area of lamb and cary
possibly armed with a knife as the first
officer arrived
the officer saw the subject still armed
with a knife bleeding
from the neck and the hands the officer
attempted to make contact with the male
he could see that the male was still
armed with a knife and told the male to
drop
the knife however the male continued to
advance upon the officer
and the officer fired his weapon the
mail went down
and the officer immediately summoned for
medical attention
medical arrived and transported the mail
to an un to a nearby hospital
the condition of the mail is still
critical these details are very
preliminary at this point
but within 72 hours the sheriff or his
designee
will come forward with all body-worn
camera video and further investigative
details
thank you
how long the officer had engaged with
the suspect before
it's still under investigation we're
still reviewing all those details we'll
make sure to get them in the next 72
hours
the original one called somebody in the
area what was the call
i haven't been able to hear the 911 call
yet at this point it'll be part of the
follow-up details was that officer
a solo officer was there a partner
thank you